McGovern Institute is a brain research
institute with a dual mission understand
the brain and then apply that knowledge
to help people suffering from many forms
of brain disorders conditions ranging
from dyslexia and autism and children to
Parkinson's disease Alzheimer's disease
macular degeneration in the elderly as
well as depression and schizophrenia the
statistics say that one in four families
are going to be affected by a brain
disorder of some form these are very
severe and painful disorders they're
painful for the people who suffer them
in their painful for their families
their relatives or friends we got to do
something when the government Institute
has been and always will be a
tremendously strong basic research
enterprise we're all united around a
common theme of understanding the brain
essentially all the way from molecules
up to cognition we currently have 16
distinguished faculty members including
one Nobel laureate than five members of
the National Academy of Sciences we
attract people who want to be part of
this team who want to work on big
problems that can't be solved by one
person working in their lab I think
McGovern Institute is one of the most
collaborative environments that I have
ever worked in one of the great
advantages of being here at the McGovern
Institute is that the whole philosophy
is risk taking this is encouraged by the
McGovern's themselves
we have created an imbued sense of
entrepreneurial research we can start
research for which no other source of
funding is available I can't think of
anything else comparable in the world
that would allow radically new ideas
from left field to get out there and in
one short year have huge impact in the
world we can do absolutely anything here
any kind of expertise we need is right
here in this building right around us I
think in my lifetime gonna see serious
improvements and our treatments of
people with brain disorders I believe we
give people hope when there is hope and
not defeat or despair on people's mind
progress will prevail and solutions will
be found in order general tip diseases
will be cured I just know that
you